so the significance of this report is it
represents the current state of all of
our understanding of the size of climate
change distilled into a few short
chapters for world leaders to digest so
this is communicating directly to
governments and what it does is urges
them to act far faster and far more
ambitiously than we've ever done before
now these reports come and go every six
or seven years I've been covering them
for about 20 years and they always say
pretty much the same thing we need to
act the issue is urgent we have little
time to act but what's fundamentally
significant about this one is that this
is possibly the last time the world
scientists will warn us how and and how
urgently we have to avoid that crucial
1.5 degrees of warming and that's
because the report finds that by the
2030s we will most likely have reach
that Target when the scientists are due
to report to us again I'm conveying that
sense of urgency was UN Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez when he
presented the report to the world
earlier
humanity is on thin ice and that ice is
melting fast I have proposed to the G20
a climate solidarity pact in which all
big emitters make extra efforts to cut
emissions and whilst your countries
mobilize financial and Technical
Resources to support emerging economies
in a common effort to keep 1.5 degrees
alive and this is the moment for all G20
members to come together in a joint
effort pulling their resources and
scientific capacities as well as their
proven and affordable Technologies
through the public and private sectors
to make carbon neutrality a reality by
2050.
the focus there on the G20 Nations on
Rich Nations to do more and there's of
course a reason for that is that it's
the rich Nations that put most of the
emissions into the atmosphere but more
significantly those that are going to
suffer most from the impact of climate
change and the report today identifies
about three and a half billion people
will be at risk overcoming decades from
climate extremes they're the ones who
are going to suffer the most yet did the
least to contribute to the problem and
because a lot of this global warming
even if we do everything we possibly can
now and avoid at 1.5 degrees warming
we're already going to see climate
extremes where we're going to see
glaciers melt and some of the worst some
of the severe impacts of climate change
anyway so there is also a call to adapt
and earlier we spoke to Dr Frederica
Frederica Otto who's one of the lead
authors of today's report about the
urgency of the adaptation problem
no matter how successful we are on
mitigation
we still need to adapt because we are
already seeing a huge amount of losses
and damages from Human induced climate
change lives are being lost livelihoods
and ecosystems and we do know how to do
what the report calls transformative
adaptation and that is uh really
reducing the vulnerability of our
societies and and ecosystems by
investing in Social Security Systems
investing in Health Care Systems
redesigning our cities
so an urgent call for more money to do
adaptation that funding has to be
immobilized but also that call from
Antonio Gutierrez to for rich countries
to massively accelerate their efforts to
reduce emissions to the atmosphere as
well because as things currently stand
even with the commitments made at the
Glasgow climate Summit recently which
will go a little bit further than the
science considered in this report we are
so very far from reducing Ambitions to
the degree that we need to in order to
prevent 1.5 degrees of warming by the